Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman
Show, I am Ferren cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David today.
You can follow me on Twitter at Fair and Balanced.
Find me on Facebook, Facebook, dotcom, fair
and balanced YouTube, YouTube, dotcom slash
the ring of Fire and my other YouTube channel,
YouTube, dotcom, fair and balanced.
Let's get back into more of some of the news
here.
And I think one of the biggest non stories
of the last week was Mike Landfill's Cyber
Symposium that, as we all know, came to a
close at the end of last week, August 13th,
came and went.
And in case you haven't noticed, Donald Trump
is still not the president of the United States,
nor did we see President Biden and Vice President
Harris resign, as Lyndell had also predicted
at one point.
Now, to his credit, sure, he had pushed back
the date of Donald Trump's reinstatement.
He said, well, it's not going to happen August
13th, maybe September.
Now he says maybe later down the road.
But now it's really looking like it's not
going to happen, as if it was ever going to
happen.
Here's the thing.
This cyber symposium was an absolute crap
show, and that is about putting it as nicely
as humanly possible.
The guy got up there on stage, kicked the
whole thing off with Steve Bannon, who, by
the way, later in the week came out and actually
criticized Lyndell for not providing any evidence
at all like the packet captures.
Where the hell were the package captures?
Because they were nowhere to be seen and of
course, the rest of the symposium was nothing
more than just power points that people had
put together with numbers that they didn't
source from anywhere.
They just said, well, here's what it was,
but here's what we think it really was.
And they provided no evidence at all to back
up their little phony numbers that they threw
up on the screens.
So, you know, there was that then, of course,
we had Michael Tyndall's own cybersecurity
expert gave an interview to The Washington
Times where he said, yeah, there was no evidence
of any hack at all.
So we could not sign off on Linda's claims
that there was a hack.
Lyndell insisted there was anyway.
And in fact, actually, when the Gateway Pundit
reported on The Washington Times interview
with that cybersecurity expert, Lyndell got
up on stage and he said, well, obviously the
Gateway pundit person is a CIA plant.
Then, of course, you had his claim that he
was assaulted in his hotel room.
Or not, his hotel room in his own hotel lobby
and no record of this, he showed up the next
day, not a scratch on him, you know, no police
report filed.
So as far as we know, there was no actual
assault that took place.
And then on Friday, at the end of all of this,
Lyndell comes out, gives an interview, basically
tried to explain away why the whole thing
was an abject failure by saying it's because
Antifa infiltrated the cyber symposium.
That was that was his excuse antifa infiltrated
the cyber symposium, they went in there, he
said they changed the name tags.
And then they disrupt that also didn't happen,
by the way, I feel the need to point that
out.
That didn't happen.
But but here's the thing.
He didn't say what they did after they changed
the name tags.
So, like, did they change the name tags and
just go sit in the crowd and watch?
Because if so, I don't think that's throwing
the whole thing off.
I think that's whatever the point is, there
was never any evidence.
And that's why that cyber symposium was a
completely fact free event.
The only part of it that was even mildly entertaining
was when he found out his lawsuit, a defamation
lawsuit against him, was going to move forward
and he bolted offstage, came back, did a seven
minute rant against a minion voting systems.
And again, in an interview after the thing
ended, he said, oh, well, we're going to we're
going to have it all on.
You had Alan Dershowitz join via Zoome, I
believe.
And Dershowitz said, oh, yeah, in the in the
lawsuit, the discovery, all this will come
out, bring it.
Dominion is clearly not afraid.
Dominion, as far as we know, has absolutely
nothing to hide, but what we do know is that
all the ridiculous claims that Michael and
Dale made on stage will be used against him
in a court of law because he won't stop the
defamation.
So, yeah, he's in trouble.
He's in a lot of trouble with his followers
because he didn't give them any information,
again, even banning the guy who is platformed
Mike Lyndell for months and months to spread
these lies, called him out for not producing
any evidence.
The packet captures that Lyndell been talking
about for months were nowhere to be seen.
And he also really destroyed any legal defense
he may have, of course, in that defamation
case.
So rather than ending with a bang, rather
than ending with the reinstatement of former
President Donald Trump, Mike Lyndell cyber
symposium ended with a whimper, a whimper
that is really going to make it hard for him
to defend himself in this Dominion defamation
lawsuit.